this next question again is actually
going to deal with projections so maybe
it was good that we looked at that last
question by getting our head into that
space
this is part c suppose that a b and c
are distinct non-zero three-dimensional
vectors with the property that and this
is obviously pretty important the
projection of a onto c is equal to the
projection of b onto c
show that a minus b is
perpendicular to c
interesting okay now this question was
um quite poorly done which is why i
think it's really worth having a close
look at and it was quite poorly done for
an interesting reason um you've got this
geometry going on here and it's fairly
um it's fairly
like repeatedly said um not least of all
by me that when you're looking at a
geometric situation like this draw a
diagram to help you out right
now
this was a really interesting question
to me because
some students drew diagrams but
unexpectedly those diagrams ended up
hurting such students rather than
helping them and i'm going to explain to
you why but before i do that i'm
actually going to show you what i think
is the cleanest solution in case you're
just wondering like okay what do i do
with this i'm going to show you the
cleanest solution and then we're going
to deal with the geometry of what's
going on here okay so
i've moved all the way into question 12.
so let's just
write that question 12
and i'm on part c all right now if um i
can start with this idea that the
projections are equal to each other
projection of a
onto c
is equal to the projection of b
onto c okay what does that mean can we
just deal with this in terms of the
formulas in terms of the definitions the
answer is yes we can and it's remarkably
straightforward
there are many ways to define the
projection but in this case in order to
make my canceling easiest i think the
one that's going to be most helpful is
the one which has all the dot products
in it and it's kind of hilarious because
it has um the base
the base vector the one that's being
projected onto over and over and over
again and that's one of the things that
i found funny about learning this
formula okay so this one this particular
form is a dot c
on
c dot c
times c
there you go there's the left hand one
and then on the right hand side
everything is the same let's just grab
that over there except of course the
vector we're projecting on is not a it's
b
like so okay
and what can you do with this well
there's lots of bits and pieces here
that you can cancel out and some of
which you don't want to right so
remembering that the goal i'm heading
towards is that uh what i'm required to
prove is that a minus b that that is
perpendicular to c right so clearly like
the way that you would show things are
perpendicular to one another is by the
dot product being equal to zero like
that's kind of why all these dot
products flying around don't make things
more complicated they actually make it
easier to get to right now in order to
show that the dot product is equal to
zero i want the dot product of this
vector a minus b so i need an a minus b
appearing somewhere here and a c
but that's it right so you can see the
c's are here and the dot products are
there so where can i take this well when
you have a look on the denominators i
hope you can see
these two you know c dot product against
itself is just going to be a constant so
therefore i can just multiply through by
that and it's going to vanish away right
in the same way these two vectors that
appear on on both sides they're
superfluous so i can divide through by
that so what does that leave me with
i've got a dot c
equals b dot c okay
now recognizing that um i can actually
get my a minus b by subtracting
that c
or that b dot c rather
from both sides getting my b's and my
tildes confused that's a bit dangerous
isn't it i've got this
and one of the great things about the
dot product is that it's a distributive
property right when you think about it's
just it's multiplication and addition
that's what's going on and that's going
to be distributive so therefore i can
take out that dot c and apply it to the
a minus b that's left right you can see
in here this a
minus b is going to become the a minus b
that i need for my actual proof so that
dot c is equal to zero therefore like
that's it right um therefore i'm just
going to grab this
sorry that's a bit lazy but you get the
drift
okay so like i said
this was probably the most
straightforward way to do it not a
difficult set of marks to get if you
knew the way to most algebraically
efficiently get there okay
but i said right at the start that this
is a question which despite it being in
geometric terms the diagrams that people
drew ended up being
a hindrance to them and i want to
explain why
several people when they had a look at
this um this result here they're like ah
the projection of a onto c and the
prediction of b onto c are the same what
might that look like now this is not a
bad way to approach the question i
really like that you wanted to think
about visually but i want you to see the
problems that ensued right so if you
imagine like here's let's let's call
this c right what would be a potential
scenario where um
the projection of a onto c is the same
as the projection of b onto c and this
was a diagram that i saw a bunch of
times if you've got some a
up here right what does the projection
of a onto c look like and the answer is
you imagine dropping this sort of
perpendicular down and then you think oh
it's the shadow right so there is that
projection of a onto c
where would it be if i could have b onto
c being the same and like i said several
people drew exactly this diagram they
had b i went a bit too fast sorry about
that b going off in this opposite
direction and they drop this again this
perpendicular like so so i've got this
right angle here
i've got whoopsie daisy get that color
right
this right angle here that matches up
with b and you can say look see there
are
shadows they line up perfectly so that's
why they're equal and even though this
is one potential situation where it
works the problem was students then
started to reason from this particular
right angle triangle the fact that there
is congruence going on here because
there's a common length in here like
this shadow um is a common sign so you
can make an argument from congruence and
then off you go
because you get two angles here that are
on the same line
but they are equal to one another so
therefore they both have to be pi on two
and there's your perpendicularity okay
but that doesn't work because it's not
the only way that this can be true let
me just give you like the most obvious
example i can think of let's just grab
this b right zoom like so i think i've
got it and let me just move it somewhere
you just put it over here right now in
this case the projection of a onto c and
b onto c it's not the exact same
interval but the lengths are the same so
therefore um you know this uh oops i
moved um i moved this along with it
which i didn't listen to um this
statement this equation is still going
to be true right because this length in
green and this length in blue are going
to be the same but you don't have this
common side that the previous geometric
argument was made on and so your whole
series of argument about why they're
congruent triangles it just collapses in
the heap i mean this angle here and this
angle here which people referred to they
no longer add up on a straight line so
you're in a lot of trouble there right
and so this this didn't work um and you
know even even going back right
looking at this kind of situation um
maybe as you're now thinking about the
geometry of this you can recognize why
this is not the only way that it works
right you can see for example um let's
just get rid of this this b all together
and what's another place where b could
go that doesn't create anything like
those congruent triangles you saw before
the answer is imagine sneaking b in here
see this imagine if this was b right
again when you draw that drop that
perpendicular down it's the same the
foot here is going to be the same and so
unsurprisingly you get the same shadow
here so the projections are equal and in
fact the thing i like about this is two
things number one you're like where are
the congruent triangles they're gone
because this situation does not demand
congruent triangles and secondly this
actually clarifies what's going on with
this situation right what is a minus b
and the answer is it's going to be
running along this um
this particular vector along here right
and you can see if you sort of do this
dot here you can see why it's going to
be right angled it's positioned at a
different spot but it's going to be
parallel to this perpendicular right so
that's why it has to be right angled
because the projection drops this
perpendicular shadow down and that's why
you have that 90 degrees right so no
congruent triangles and this situation
you can see is it's hard to generalize
which is actually exactly why the
algebra is the best way to go
the algebra is brilliant because no
matter what the geometric situation
looks like where this thing is where it
belongs it could be flying off somewhere
completely separate right the algebra
still holds and that's why this is one
of those very very few examples where
drawing a diagram was dangerous because
you
went away from the generality that
algebra gives you to a specific
geometric situation and the geometric
reasoning that you use was tied to that
situation and so it wasn't valid um for
any a and
b and c where this particular property
was true okay so
pretty tricky one but i you can't be
blamed for i'm being tripped up by it
because it was a pretty curvy curveball